people don't realize if you even if
you're willing you never a kid like
there's so much going on if you have a
baby like not only your body is just
giving up um but your emotional state
it's kind of crazy so like somebody
talking to someone that's just had a
baby and a photo shoot saying oh you
need to lose it that will send you in a
spiral ya know the hormones are crazy
and no one talks about it the hormones
after pregnancy for me were crazier than
when I was pregnant and it took forever
for them to calm down like months after
breastfeeding I might still be informing
off here's my best month is my best so I
was I freaked out cuz I had to I was
pumping cuz I was working this thing
which is the worst pumping is the worst
work it's so painful I don't care what
anyone says anyway but somebody had kind
of tossed out and it was only a tiny bit
of breast milk left and the bottle no I
lost my everliving might like a crazy
person went in my closet and just blew
like collapsed on the floor much crying
cause I was like you have no idea I work
for that yes and really there was like
nothing in the bottle I'm crazy but it
literally is just a hormonal period I
don't think people take that into
account especially when we're women in
the public eye like it is a hard time
and our energy is literally being sucked
out of us so you don't feel like
yourself you don't literally it out of
you it is so difficult and something
people need to talk about more died a
hundred percent I talk about it any
chance I can yeah I complain about
pregnancy without any chance I can I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this